Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. To be born, or at any rate bred in a handbag, whether it had handles or not, seems to me to display a contempt for the ordinary decencies of family life that reminds one of the worst excesses of the French Revolution. So said Lady Bracknell in Oscar wilde's importance of being earnest an attitude towards the french revolution that has been a very popular one in britain in particular but might perhaps be considered slightly unfair with me is uh stalwart john bull
感谢您收听《历史余温》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。“出生于手提包中，或者说至少是在手提包里被抚养长大，无论它有没有提手，在我看来，这都表现出对家庭生活基本礼仪的蔑视，让人想起法国大革命中最糟糕的暴行。”这是奥斯卡·王尔德在《认真的重要性》中布拉克内尔夫人所说的话。这种对法国大革命的态度在英国尤为流行，但或许被认为有些不公。和我在一起的是……呃，坚定的约翰牛（英国人的代称）。
dominic sandbrook dominic so i Tom, you're Lady Bracknell. Would you agree with Lady Bracknell on that? I think, first of all, rest of history listeners will surely agree with me that you are the great lost Lady Bracknell of our time. Can you do a handbag? Can you say a handbag in that crevice way? A handbag?
多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。多米尼克，那么汤姆，你是布拉克内尔夫人。你会同意布拉克内尔夫人的观点吗？首先，我想《历史余温》的听众肯定会同意我的看法，那就是你是我们这个时代失落已久的伟大布拉克内尔夫人。你能演一下手提包吗？你能用那种尖刻的方式说“手提包”吗？一个手提包？
Oh, my God. Is it Tom Holland or is it Margaret Thatcher? You decide. Well, so I'm kind of of Holland or is it Margaret Thatcher? You decide. Well, so I'm kind of of the Lady Bracknell school on the French Revolution. I take quite a dim... You stun me. I take a very Burkean view of it. And I think, actually, it slightly bewilders me that people, even in France, don't take a more dim view of it, given the death toll.
哦，天哪。到底是汤姆·霍兰还是玛格丽特·撒切尔？由你来决定。好吧，我算是布拉克内尔夫人那一派的，对法国大革命持相当……你让我震惊了。我对此持非常伯克式的观点。而且我认为，考虑到死亡人数，人们——即使是在法国——竟然没有对此持更负面的看法，这让我感到有些困惑。
I mean, the death toll alone is just, frankly, astounding. You know, when you think how much fuss there is in Britain about the Peterloo massacre, and in France, you're talking about a quarter of a million people, maybe more. But your attitude wouldn't be that you can't make an omelette without breaking some eggs. Well, they didn't make the omelette. I mean, that's the...
我的意思是，单是死亡人数就坦率地说令人震惊。你知道，当你想到英国对彼得卢屠杀事件有多么大惊小怪时，而在法国，你谈论的是二十五万人，甚至更多。但你的态度不会是“不打破鸡蛋就做不成煎蛋卷”吧？好吧，他们根本没做成煎蛋卷。我的意思是，这就是……
They just dropped them all over the floor. Yeah, they just smashed up a load of eggs. Slept up on their arse. This is quality historical punditry, isn't it? It's a shame we're doing this in the beginning of the episode. I presume we have no listeners left. Okay, well, Dominic, let's try and get some quality historical punditry here. Could you, for the benefit of those of us who may not be completely on top of the details
他们只是把鸡蛋全摔在地板上了。是的，他们只是打碎了一堆鸡蛋。摔了个屁股蹲儿。这就是高质量的历史评论，不是吗？真遗憾我们在节目开头就这么干了。我猜我们已经没有听众了。好吧，多米尼克，让我们试着在这里进行一些高质量的历史评论。为了那些可能不太了解细节的听众，你能简要介绍一下法国大革命是如何开始的吗？
of how the French Revolution begins, just give us a brief kind of account of how it all kicks off? Okay, well, this is a massive topic, so it's going to be very oversimplified. But basically, France has been top nation for about 150 years. It's extremely big by European standards. It's very rich. It's very populous. And then it all kind of goes wrong. We did the Seven Years' War last week with Dan Snow. So people will know that the French lost the first sort of real global conflict to the British. And by the 1780s, France is suffering from a series of interlinked problems. Now, the French Revolution is not one event. It's a process. And it's not something that anybody plans. It's not a protest about inequality,
好的，这是一个宏大的话题，所以会非常简化。但基本上，法国在过去150年里一直是顶级强国。按欧洲标准来看，它非常大。它非常富有，人口众多。然后一切都出了问题。我们上周和丹·斯诺一起聊了七年战争。所以人们会知道，法国在第一次真正的全球冲突中输给了英国。到了18世纪80年代，法国正遭受一系列相互关联的问题。法国大革命不是一个单一事件，而是一个过程。它不是任何人计划好的。它不是对不平等的抗议，
which people often think. And nor is it an uprising of the poor against the rich. It's none of those things. Where it comes from, I guess, is that France has got three interlinked problems. One is there's a general kind of economic depression, economic discontent. Its population has massively exploded, by far the most populous nation in Europe.
人们经常这样认为。它也不是穷人对富人的起义。它根本不是这些。它的根源，我想，是因为法国有三个相互关联的问题。一是普遍的经济萧条和经济不满。它的人口大幅爆炸，是欧洲人口最多的国家，遥遥领先。
But it's got huge unemployment. There's not enough jobs for everybody. Food prices have gone through the roof. There's not enough food being produced. So in other words, you've got a lot of people, let's say in Paris, you've got a third of the population of Paris. These are kind of young people. So they're in their 20s and 30s.
但它有巨大的失业率。没有足够的工作岗位给每个人。食品价格飞涨。生产的粮食不足。所以换句话说，你有很多人，比如在巴黎，巴黎三分之一的人口。他们是年轻人。所以他们处于二三十岁。
They don't have a job and they don't have any food and they're cross about it and sort of discontent is rising. So that's the first thing. Second thing is that France is heavily indebted because of all these wars it's been fighting. Now, it's not the only country in Europe with debts, but it finds it's very hard to service its debts. Its tax raising system and its political system is incredibly antiquated and complicated. And the King Louis XVI can't get enough money to pay his debts. So France is basically on the verge of bankruptcy. And the third thing that compounds all that is just bad luck. They have a series of terrible harvests. There's a really, really bad weather, terrible winter in 1788-89. So people are starving on the streets.
他们没有工作，也没有食物，他们对此感到愤怒，不满情绪正在上升。这是第一件事。第二件事是法国因为一直在打这些战争而背负沉重债务。现在，它不是欧洲唯一有债务的国家，但它发现偿还债务非常困难。它的税收制度和政治制度极其陈旧且复杂。国王路易十六无法筹集到足够的钱来偿还债务。所以法国基本上处于破产边缘。第三件加剧这一切的事情就是运气不好。他们经历了一系列糟糕的收成。1788-89年的天气非常糟糕，冬天极其寒冷。所以人们在街上挨饿。
So Louis XVI decides he's been in power for, what, 15 years or so. He's not a bad man. He's indecisive. But he's one of these monarchs from the 18th century who's kind of an enlightened figure. He wants a more modern, streamlined system. And to do do that he needs to recall something called the estates general which is this sort of french equivalent of parliament if you like there has come and there are three estates there are three estates there's an ability the clergy and the third estate which is basically everybody else and it hasn't met since 1614 and he says he needs to get them to come back to to come and meet at
所以路易十六决定——他已经掌权15年左右了。他不是个坏人。他优柔寡断。但他属于18世纪那种开明君主。他想要一个更现代、更精简的制度。为了做到这一点，他需要召集所谓的“三级会议”，如果你愿意的话，这相当于法国的议会。有三个等级，有三个等级：贵族、教士和第三等级，基本上就是其他人。它自1614年以来就没有召开过。他说他需要让他们回来，在……
versailles and the reason he needs them to meet is he needs them to come back to to come and meet at versailles and the reason he needs them to meet is he needs them to agree on a new system so that he can raise some money and basically stave off france's looming bankruptcy and sort the government out so they they all pitch up and the third estate this is where kind of enlightened ideas and stuff come in the third estate are not content to just be sort of third fiddlers, as it were. As they had been in the 17th century. Yes, they've always been outvoted by the nobility and the clergy.
凡尔赛宫。他需要他们开会的原因是，他需要他们回来，在凡尔赛宫开会。他需要他们开会的原因是，他需要他们就一套新制度达成一致，这样他才能筹集资金，基本上避免法国迫在眉睫的破产，并整顿政府。所以他们都赶来了，而第三等级——这就是开明思想之类发挥作用的地方——第三等级不满足于仅仅扮演“第三小提琴手”的角色，就像他们在17世纪那样。是的，他们总是被贵族和教士投票否决。
They don't want to be, they basically are all these sort of lawyers and stuff who with their minds full of kind of enlightened ideas. So trouble. Yeah, so trouble for the king. They're not going to be pushed around. He basically said, you know, they fall out with the other estates. He wants to get rid of them. He thinks this has all been a terrible idea. Actually,
他们不想这样，他们基本上都是那些满脑子开明思想的律师之类的人。所以麻烦来了。是的，国王的麻烦来了。他们不会任人摆布。他基本上说，你知道，他们和其他等级闹翻了。他想摆脱他们。他认为这整个主意糟透了。实际上，
this isn't working out very well at all. So they all go to a tennis court at Versailles, and they swear an oath that they're not going to leave unless they get a constitution and they basically get the new system that they want. Now, that's all very political and dry. But at the same time, in Paris Paris discontent on the streets is reaching a crescendo people are starving people are angry um the Louis tries to get rid of his chief minister and at that point that sort of crowds start rioting they attack the Bastille this prison in the center of Paris that's a symbol of um royalist rule it's basically got nobody in it's got seven prisoners in it most of whom are forgers but it's sort of seen as a symbol of royalist rule. It's basically got nobody in it. It's got seven prisoners in it, most of whom are forgers.
这根本行不通。所以他们都去了凡尔赛宫的一个网球场，并发誓除非得到一部宪法，否则绝不离开，他们基本上得到了他们想要的新制度。现在，这听起来非常政治化且枯燥。但与此同时，在巴黎，街头的不满情绪正达到高潮，人们在挨饿，人们很愤怒。路易试图解雇他的首席大臣，就在那时，人群开始暴动，他们袭击了巴士底狱——这座位于巴黎市中心的监狱是保皇派统治的象征。它里面基本上没人，只有七名囚犯，大多数是伪造犯，但它被视为保皇派统治的象征。它里面基本上没人。它只有七名囚犯，大多数是伪造犯。
But it's sort of seen as the symbol of royal tyranny. They attack the Bastille. The Bastille falls. There are lynchings. And at that point, even at that very early stage, I would say Louis has kind of lost control of this process that he has set in motion. He wants to reform.
但它被视为王权暴政的象征。他们袭击了巴士底狱。巴士底狱陷落了。发生了私刑。就在那一刻，即使是在那个非常早期的阶段，我想说路易已经失去了对他所引发的这个过程的控制。他想要改革。
He's a bit of a Mikhail Gorbachev figure, I think. He wants to reform the system and to sort it out and to modernize it. But he's done it at the worst possible time with immense sort of anger and resentment on the streets of Paris. So Paris is this sort of seething cauldron of revolutionary ferment. And at that point, the process begins to spin away from him. And then you get a series of assemblies and clubs and political factions, and the revolution then starts to sort of take its course. And there is this incredible sense throughout the whole process that people assume that it can't go any further.
我认为他有点像米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫。他想改革制度，整顿它，使它现代化。但他选择的时机最糟糕，巴黎街头充满了巨大的愤怒和怨恨。所以巴黎是一个沸腾的革命发酵大锅。就在那一刻，这个过程开始脱离他的控制。然后你得到了一系列议会、俱乐部和政治派别，革命就开始走上自己的道路。在整个过程中，有一种令人难以置信的感觉，人们认为它不会再进一步了。
So that oath in the tennis court is the 20th of June. And on the 27th of June, there's an Englishman in Paris, a guy called Arthur Young. Oh, yes. I know this quote. It's a great quote. So this is one week after. The whole business now seems over and the revolution complete. Yeah. And basically for the next, what, 10 years, maybe? I mean, you could even say the next two centuries, perhaps. People keep saying that, don't they? They keep saying the revolution is over.
所以网球场宣誓是在6月20日。6月27日，巴黎有一位英国人，一个叫阿瑟·扬的人。哦，是的。我知道这句名言。这是一句很棒的名言。所以这是在一周后。“整个事情现在似乎结束了，革命完成了。”是的。基本上在接下来的，怎么说，10年里，也许吧？我的意思是，你甚至可以说接下来的两个世纪，也许。人们一直在说，不是吗？他们一直在说革命结束了。
Yeah, they do. And I think one of the things about the French Revolution that makes it so fun to study is that no one's in charge of it. So it's not quite like the Russian Revolution, where when Lenin comes into the story in the Russian Revolution, Lenin is clearly the mastermind and the Bolsheviks have a plan.
是的，他们确实在说。我认为法国大革命之所以研究起来如此有趣，原因之一就是没有人能掌控它。所以它不像俄国革命，在俄国革命中，当列宁进入故事时，列宁显然是策划者，布尔什维克有一个计划。
And the Russian Revolution is following, you know, they're responding to events the Russian revolution is following, you know, they're responding to events, but it's following, you know, they have a sort of vague sense of a blueprint. In the French revolution, there's never one person or one party that's really in control. There are a series of factions fighting constantly. And that's why the revolution keeps on, as you say, it keeps on rolling. And you think, well, it's not going to go any further, but it always does. And I think partly because war enters the equation. I think it's violent from the beginning,
俄国革命是在跟随，你知道，他们在响应事件。俄国革命是在跟随，你知道，他们在响应事件，但它是在跟随，你知道，他们有一种模糊的蓝图感。在法国大革命中，从来没有一个人或一个政党真正掌控局面。有一系列派别在不断斗争。这就是为什么革命正如你所说，一直在滚动。你以为，好吧，它不会再进一步了，但它总是会。我认为部分原因是战争进入了等式。我认为它从一开始就是暴力的，
but once war enters the equation, once France declares war on its neighbours and the war starts to go badly, then everything is under this sort of cloud of paranoia and anxiety and fear and stuff. Would you say that the revolution, in a sense, is a sequence of experiments? Because France has had the Ancien Régime. By definition, it's deeply entrenched. It's absolutely rooted in the fabric of French history. You get rid of it, then you have to try
但一旦战争进入等式，一旦法国向邻国宣战，战争开始变得糟糕，那么一切都笼罩在偏执、焦虑和恐惧的阴云之下。你会说革命在某种意义上是一系列实验吗？因为法国有旧制度。根据定义，它根深蒂固。它绝对植根于法国历史的结构中。你摆脱了它，然后你就必须尝试
and replace it with something else. So the summer of 17 of 1789 is basically i mean it's kind of an attempt to put in in process enlightenment ideals and perhaps with a nod to the the model of the the british mixed constitution so uh so you have um the uh the declaration of the rights of man and the citizen which is absolutely kind of rooted in the Enlightenment ideal. If only we follow enlightened process, then everything will be great. You have a meeting of all the nobles who furiously give away all their feudal privileges in a kind of joyous sense that this is, you know, what fun, let's get rid of this. Everything's going to be great. Well, some of them do anyway yeah yeah but the assumption is is that if you do the right thing
用别的东西来代替它。所以1789年的夏天基本上，我的意思是，这是一种试图将启蒙思想付诸实践的尝试，也许还向英国混合宪法的模式致敬。所以，你有……“人权和公民权宣言”，它绝对植根于启蒙运动的理想。如果我们遵循开明的过程，那么一切都会很好。你有一场所有贵族参加的会议，他们狂热地放弃了所有的封建特权，带着一种快乐的感觉，认为这，你知道，多有趣啊，让我们摆脱这些吧。一切都会好起来的。好吧，他们中有些人确实这么做了。是的，是的，但假设是如果你做了正确的事，
then everything will turn out great and then it's it it kind of turns out not to and then over as you say over the the year and a half that follows you start to move towards a republican system because actually like the english civil war it does not begin in any way with, you know, republicanism is a really, really minority interest. Yeah, that's absolutely right. So basically, nobody wants a republic in 1789. I think you're dead right, Tom. Everybody thinks they're going to get a constitutional monarchy.
那么一切都会变得很好，然后结果却并非如此。然后正如你所说，在接下来的一年半里，你开始走向共和制度，因为实际上，就像英国内战一样，它绝不是以……你知道，共和主义是一个非常、非常少数人的兴趣。是的，那绝对正确。所以基本上，1789年没有人想要共和国。我想你是对的，汤姆。每个人都认为他们会得到一个君主立宪制。
The problem is Louis XVI, he doesn't really want to be a constitutional monarch. He just wants more money, basically. He wants the system to work better. But also, none of them really bargain for the fact that i think they don't bargain for the war so they don't but they they actually go into the war it's france that declares war on its neighbors but they think they're going to win i mean they they don't they never expect that the war will go against them so that radicalizes everything but also i think what these guys in paris don't get, you know, these are most of the revolutionaries, the sort of standard figures that we all,
问题是路易十六，他并不真的想成为一个君主立宪制的君主。他基本上只是想要更多的钱。他希望制度运作得更好。但同样，他们都没有预料到战争，所以他们没有……但他们实际上进入了战争，是法国向邻国宣战，但他们认为他们会赢。我的意思是，他们从没预料到战争会不利于他们，所以这使一切激进化了。但我也认为，巴黎的这些家伙不明白的是，你知道，这些是大多数革命者，我们大家都听说过的那些标准人物，
you know, everyone's heard of, even if they don't know about the French Revolution, the sort of Robespierre types. These are very high-minded, young, very well-educated lawyers, people from kind of middle class, bourgeois families, and so on. And I think what they don't get is out in the countryside i mean france is a very big place um by european standards front and it's very rural and out in those places people don't actually really want the revolution you know they they they're things like the catholic church the revolutionists want to get rid of they like all that they just want to be better off they don't want to destroy all the world that they've grown up with but isn't it also the case that in in paris that the sans-culottes the you know the the the what i guess um lady bracknell would call the mob the mob yeah um they also are kind of they're another source of pressure and in a sense they are more important than you than what peasants are doing in the Vendee.
即使他们不了解法国大革命，比如罗伯斯庇尔那种类型。这些都是非常高尚、年轻、受过良好教育的律师，来自中产阶级、资产阶级家庭的人等等。我认为他们不明白的是在农村——我的意思是，按欧洲标准来看，法国是一个非常大的地方，而且非常乡村化——在那些地方，人们实际上并不真的想要革命。你知道，他们……像天主教会，革命者想要摆脱它，他们喜欢所有这些，他们只是想过得更好，他们不想摧毁他们从小长大的整个世界。但难道不是在巴黎，无套裤汉——你知道，我猜布拉克内尔夫人会称之为“暴民”——暴民，是的，他们也是另一种压力来源，在某种意义上，他们比旺代省的农民所做的更重要吗？
Absolutely. Because Paris is where it all matters. And so in a sense, increasingly, although it's the lawyers and so on who are making the running, it's people who are equivalent to people who write in The Guardian who are pushing it. Yeah.
绝对是。因为巴黎是所有事情都重要的地方。所以从某种意义上说，虽然是律师们在推动，是那些相当于为《卫报》写稿的人在推动。是的。
They've kind of got a, you know, they're holding onto a wolf by its ears. Yeah. They are kind, they've kind of got a, you know, they're holding onto a wolf by its ears. Yeah, they are. I think they're, and you say about the sans-culottes, I mean, the sans-culottes are people, you know, without knee bridges. So they're sort of raggedy people. And the pressure that's coming from the streets of Paris is coming
他们有点像，你知道，他们抓住了狼的耳朵。是的。他们有点像，你知道，他们抓住了狼的耳朵。是的，他们是。我想他们是，你说到无套裤汉，我的意思是，无套裤汉是那些，你知道，没有膝裤的人。所以他们是那种衣衫褴褛的人。来自巴黎街头的压力来自于
from people who often don't have a job and who are desperate for bread. And food prices are rocketing and they want cheap bread and that's their main priority. But of course, like all, as we know with revolutions, when you have groups of quite young people who don't have a job, who are basically loitering on the streets all the time, there is almost an inbuilt sort of a ratchet,
那些经常没有工作、渴望面包的人。食品价格飞涨，他们想要便宜的面包，这是他们的首要任务。但当然，像所有革命一样，正如我们所知，当你有一群相当年轻、没有工作、基本上整天在街上游荡的人时，几乎有一种内在的棘轮效应，
a kind of radicalising effect. And I think a lot of these politicians are frightened of the mob and are, you know, as you say, they're trying to sort of ride the tiger and they're constantly thinking, you know, what do the mob want? What can we give them? You know, how can we harness this to our advantage? But the mob are also a kind of constant temptation because they, so there are the women who get sent off to Versailles to bring the king and queen back to Paris. So that's a kind of eruption. And then they kind of get suppressed.
一种激进化的效果。我认为很多政客都害怕暴民，而且，你知道，正如你所说，他们试图“骑虎难下”，他们不断地想，你知道，暴民想要什么？我们能给他们什么？你知道，我们如何利用这一点来为我们谋利？但暴民也是一种持续的诱惑，因为他们……所以有那些被派往凡尔赛宫把国王和王后带回巴黎的妇女。所以那是一种爆发。然后他们被镇压了。
And then when the king and the queen decide that they've had enough and they run off to Varennes. Yeah. And then they're brought back in disgrace. Yes. And then essentially to try and stir things up, then the mob are given their head again. Yeah. I mean, that's what the politicians keep doing, is giving the mob their head.
然后当国王和王后决定他们受够了，他们逃往瓦雷纳。是的。然后他们被羞辱地带了回来。是的。然后基本上为了试图搅动局势，暴民又被放出来了。是的。我的意思是，这就是政客们一直在做的，给暴民自由。
So the Paris Commune, the sections, as they're called, there's these sort of two parallel power structures, I guess. So there's the National Assembly, or then the Convention as it becomes, and then there's the pressure from the Commune. And the National Assembly, that's what the estates had been. So the Third Estate go off to their tennis court, and then the nobles and the priests join them,
所以巴黎公社，那些所谓的“区”，有两种平行的权力结构，我想。所以有国民议会，或者后来成为国民公会，然后有来自公社的压力。而国民议会，那就是三级会议曾经的样子。所以第三等级去了他们的网球场，然后贵族和教士加入了他们，
and they all become citizens, and they all become, they are the nation in assembly. So you have a series of, I mean, anyone who's listened to this, who's done this at sort of A-level or something will know just how fiendishly complex this all is. But there's a nationalist, there's a legislative, there's a constituent assembly, a legislative assembly, and then a national convention.
他们都成了公民，他们都成了，他们是集会中的国家。所以你有一系列……我的意思是，任何听过这个节目，在A-level（英国高中课程）之类的课程中学习过的人都会知道这有多么极其复杂。但有一个国民议会，有一个立法议会，然后是一个国民公会。
But basically, you know, it's exactly that. It's kind of a big, you know, it's where we get the idea of left and right from, actually. You know, this sort of big hall, people shouting at each other, the classic kind of parliamentary model, I guess. Yes. Well, OK, so just a couple of questions here, which shows just how influential the French Revolution has been and continues to be. So there's one from Lucius. Why was the French Revolution a horrible mistake? And one from John. Why was the French Revolution the right thing to do?
但基本上，你知道，正是那样。这是一种巨大的，你知道，这就是我们得到“左派”和“右派”概念的地方，实际上。你知道，这种大厅，人们互相大喊大叫，经典的议会模式，我想。是的。好吧，那么这里有几个问题，这显示了法国大革命的影响力有多大，并且持续存在。所以有一个来自卢修斯的问题：“为什么法国大革命是一个可怕的错误？”还有一个来自约翰的问题：“为什么法国大革命是正确的做法？”
Oh, there you go. Well, so what you see, I would probably say, I think the mistake is an interesting one because it's a mistake in the sense that nobody gets what they wanted. Nobody gets what they that they thought they were going to have so although in sort of 1790 or 1791 within a year or so of it of it happening of it beginning the process um there is a sort of sense at that point well maybe it's going to be all right you know maybe the national assembly is passing a lot of reforms they're sort of nationalizing
哦，给你。好吧，所以你看到的，我可能会说，我认为“错误”是一个有趣的问题，因为它是一个错误，在这个意义上，没有人得到他们想要的。没有人得到他们认为他们会拥有的东西。所以虽然在1790年或1791年左右，在它发生、开始过程的一年左右，在那一点上有一种感觉，好吧，也许一切都会好起来的，你知道，也许国民议会正在通过许多改革，他们正在将……
church lands okay well can i just dominic so there's a question here from Brian Williams. Could the French Revolution have been averted in 1789? Well, no, because the process, a French Revolution, was always going to happen because France... Because it had run out of money. It had run out of money. It's bankruptcy. Bankruptcy is the key fact that means that some change is going to have to be introduced.
教会土地国有化。好吧，我能插一句吗，多米尼克？这里有一个来自布莱恩·威廉姆斯的问题：“法国大革命能在1789年避免吗？”好吧，不能，因为这个过程，法国大革命，总是会发生的，因为法国……因为它没钱了。它没钱了。它是破产。破产是关键事实，意味着必须引入某种变革。
I think so, because I think, in a way, France was the victim of its own success because it had been so successful for 200 years, basically. They hadn't needed to modernize and come up with all kinds of sort of clever financial instrument and political instruments, as for example, the Dutch Republic or Britain had. Smaller countries that had to kind of innovate to keep up with France. France hadn't needed to do that. It had this very antiquated political and economic and financial system. So they were going to have to change that at some point. The problem they had was that Louis does it and he's not very decisive.
我想是的，因为我认为，在某种程度上，法国是自身成功的受害者，因为它在200年里一直非常成功，基本上。他们不需要现代化，不需要想出各种巧妙的金融工具和政治工具，比如荷兰共和国或英国。那些必须创新以跟上法国步伐的小国。法国不需要那样做。它有这种非常陈旧的政治、经济和金融体系。所以他们必须在某个时候改变这一点。他们面临的问题是路易做了这件事，但他不是很果断。
So he doesn't really know what he wants. They're doing it at a point when he can't, you know, he doesn't have much public support because people are hungry and prices are rocketing. They've lost a lot of wars. So he doesn't have that much political capital. Dom, counter view to that i mean it isn't there is a kind of revisionist take and i absolutely not my period so i may be wrong with this but there is a kind of opinion that actually the ancien regime kind of at the at the at certain levels was reforming itself that's simon charmer's take for example very talented very able people were starting to come through and that in a sense the
所以他并不真正知道他想要什么。他们是在他无法……你知道，他没有多少公众支持的时候做这件事，因为人们很饿，价格飞涨。他们输掉了很多战争。所以他没有那么多的政治资本。多姆，对此的反面观点是，我的意思是，难道没有一种修正主义的观点吗？我绝对不是研究这个时期的，所以我可能错了，但有一种观点认为，实际上旧制度在某些层面上正在自我改革。比如西蒙·沙玛的观点，非常有才华、非常有能力的人开始崭露头角，在某种意义上，
the tornado of the revolution slightly threw them off course um i mean do you give credibility to that i do give a bit of credibility to that actually i think um it didn't have to unfold as disastrous as it did and the common view the sort of Dickensian view, if you like, which is of... So the view that we have in Britain of the French Revolution is sort of Charles Dickens' view that it's this complete sort of bloodbath preceded by grotesque inequality and exploitation
革命的龙卷风稍微让他们偏离了轨道。我的意思是，你相信这一点吗？我确实相信一点，实际上。我认为它不必像那样灾难性地展开。常见的观点，如果你愿意的话，那种狄更斯式的观点，也就是……所以我们在英国对法国大革命的看法是查尔斯·狄更斯式的观点，即这是一场完全的血洗，之前是怪诞的不平等和剥削，
and all this sort of stuff. And neither of those things is quite true. So the Ancien Regime is, you know, Louis and the people around him are much more thoughtful and, I mean, less sort of ultra-reactionary than we often remember. I mean, Louis is not really a tyrant. He's just trying to do his best in a pretty difficult job. And he loves keys, doesn't he?
以及所有这些东西。这两者都不完全正确。所以旧制度是，你知道，路易和周围的人比我们经常记得的要深思熟虑得多，我的意思是，没那么极端反动。我的意思是，路易并不是一个暴君。他只是在做一份相当困难的工作，尽力而为。他喜欢钥匙，不是吗？
Does he? Yeah, keys and locks. Oh, yes, I did know something about this. Because he was having problems consummating his marriage. Yes, he did. That's right, yeah. He had some sort of gynecological issues, if that's not the right word. I think he had a problematic foreskin.
是吗？是的，钥匙和锁。哦，是的，我确实知道这件事。因为他在圆房方面遇到了问题。是的，他确实遇到了。那是对的，是的。他有一些妇科方面的问题，如果这不是正确的词的话。我想他的包皮有问题。
Yeah, I think that's that. To be resolved by surgery. But also Marion Swinette, she gets a dreadful press. Okay, well, Dominic, you have mentioned Simon Sharma, who, of course, Citizens is, it was Anglophone historiography's contribution to the Bicentennial celebrations. And Citizens famously basically said it was violent right from the beginning.
是的，我想是那样。需要通过手术解决。但还有玛丽·安托瓦内特，她受到了可怕的媒体攻击。好吧，多米尼克，你提到了西蒙·沙玛，当然，《公民》是英语史学界对二百周年纪念的贡献。而《公民》著名地基本上说它从一开始就是暴力的。
But we have a question from Simon Sharma. That's very gratifying. Which is kind of embarrassing, isn't it? Yeah. No pressure. But he asks, why was the revolution so brutal to women? I guess in a sense, I mean, look at it in the general, but the figure of Marie Antoinette is kind of paradigmatic in this.
但我们有一个来自西蒙·沙玛的问题。这非常令人欣慰。这有点尴尬，不是吗？是的。没有压力。但他问：“为什么革命对女性如此残酷？”我想在某种意义上，我的意思是，从总体上看，但玛丽·安托瓦内特的形象在其中是典型的。
Yeah. Well, he writes about this himself. I mean, he knows the answer to this question, I'm sure. But when I thought about it, he's absolutely right. The French Revolution, there are sort of a handful of very famous women associated with it. Marie Antoinette, executed.
是的。好吧，他自己也写过这个。我的意思是，我相信他知道这个问题的答案。但当我思考它时，他是绝对正确的。法国大革命，有少数几个与之相关的非常著名的女性。玛丽·安托瓦内特，被处决。
Charlotte Corday, the assassin of Marat, executed. Madame Roland, who has this literary salon, executed. Charlotte Corday, the assassin of Marat, executed. Madame Roland, who has this literary salon, executed. And Olly de Gouges, feminist. Yes, who pushes the citizens' death and the rights of women and the citizens' death. Yeah, exactly. Also executed. So basically, if you're a notable woman in the French Revolution,
夏洛特·科黛，马拉的刺客，被处决。罗兰夫人，她有这个文学沙龙，被处决。夏洛特·科黛，马拉的刺客，被处决。罗兰夫人，她有这个文学沙龙，被处决。还有奥兰普·德·古热，女权主义者。是的，她推动了公民死亡和妇女权利。是的，完全正确。也被处决了。所以基本上，如果你是法国大革命中的知名女性，
you're going to end up dead. But these women, and marion toinette they are the victims of intense misogyny so marion toinette has been lampooned in all these pamphlets for sort of 20 years or so really scatological pornography yeah i was about to say really scatological pornographic pamphlets incredibly vicious i mean she's very there's no doubt she's very extravagant and she's very conservative. She's an Austrian princess. But is she? Because based on my viewing of Sofia Coppola's classic starring Kirsten Dunst,
你最终会死。但这些女性，还有玛丽·安托瓦内特，她们是强烈厌女症的受害者。所以玛丽·安托瓦内特在所有这些小册子中被讽刺了20年左右，真的是排泄物般的色情作品。是的，我正要说，非常恶毒的色情小册子，极其恶毒。我的意思是，毫无疑问她非常奢侈，而且她非常保守。她是一位奥地利公主。但她是吗？因为根据我对索菲亚·科波拉执导、克尔斯滕·邓斯特主演的经典电影的观看，
which when my daughters were growing up was their go-to film, it was their favourite film. So Marie Antoinette for them was a kind of real icon and i think oddly that film is kind of true to the sense of marie antoinette as this kind of rousseauist figure that she's all about um leading her life naturally living her own truth while also keeping hold of the uh you know all the privileges of um of monarchy. So there is a slight kind of Meghan quality. Oh, God, that's harsh.
当我的女儿们长大时，那是她们的首选电影，是她们最喜欢的电影。所以对她们来说，玛丽·安托瓦内特是一种真正的偶像。而且我认为奇怪的是，那部电影在某种程度上忠实于玛丽·安托瓦内特作为这种卢梭式人物的感觉，即她的一切都是关于自然地生活，活出自己的真相，同时又保持着……你知道，君主制的所有特权。所以有一种轻微的“梅根”特质。哦，天哪，那太刻薄了。
But I think Marion Twinnett deserves better. She wants her cake. And eats it very nicely. Well, she famously doesn't say. She absolutely... Which she didn't say, yes, I know. Howard Rogers says, what kind of cake should we let them eat? But this is Rousseau's line. Rousseau came up with this line.
但我认为玛丽·安托瓦内特值得更好的对待。她想要她的蛋糕。而且吃得很好。好吧，她著名地没有说。她绝对……她没说，是的，我知道。霍华德·罗杰斯说，我们应该让她们吃什么样的蛋糕？但这句是卢梭的台词。卢梭想出了这句台词。
It says the story that a princess had once said, let them eat cake. But he said that before Maritza and I had even come to France. So she never says that. You are like her, aren't you? She does have this nice little farm in her palace where she goes and pretends to be a milkmaid and stuff. But that's absolutely standard for an 18th century aristocrat. Her little farm is no more extravagant than anybody else's. But I think it is slightly different, because I think that a French queen is expected
它说的是一位公主曾经说过，“让他们吃蛋糕”的故事。但他是在玛丽·安托瓦内特甚至还没来法国之前就说了。所以她从来没说过。你就像她一样，不是吗？她在她的宫殿里确实有一个不错的小农场，她去那里假装成挤奶女工之类的。但这对于18世纪的贵族来说是绝对标准的。她的小农场并不比任何人的更奢侈。但我认为它确实有点不同，因为我认为法国王后被期望
to behave in a kind of more formal or austere, certainly subordinate and submissive role. And Marie Antoinette is kind of very, very influenced by the cult of sensibility. So she's hugely into, you know, Rousseau's novels and Richardson and all that kind of stuff. But also, Tom, I think that women queens, you see this so often in history. You see it with, you know, Alexandra, with Nicholas II's wife in Russia. You see it with Henrietta Maria, with Charles I's wife in England in the 1630s and 40s. So often the figure of the foreign queen becomes this kind of lining rod. And people project all this stuff onto the queen. Well, she's Austrian, isn't she?
以一种更正式或更朴素、当然是下属和顺从的角色行事。而玛丽·安托瓦内特在某种程度上非常、非常受“感性崇拜”的影响。所以她非常沉迷于，你知道，卢梭的小说和理查森等等。但同样，汤姆，我认为女性王后，你在历史上经常看到这一点。你在俄国看到尼古拉二世的妻子亚历山德拉，你在英国17世纪30年代和40年代看到查理一世的妻子亨利埃塔·玛丽亚。所以外国王后的形象经常成为这种避雷针。人们把所有这些东西投射到王后身上。好吧，她是奥地利的，不是吗？
And Austria is the hereditary enemy. Yeah, exactly. So she's the Austrian whore. And people say of her, you know, she's brought in these Germanic sexual practices, by which they mean lesbianism, which is a complete myth and a complete invention. But they use this as a stick with which to beat her. So I think women do get a generally a very rough ride in the french revolution but all of them so even um so so madame du barry who was louis the 15th's
而奥地利是世仇。是的，完全正确。所以她是“奥地利妓女”。人们说她，你知道，她带来了这些日耳曼的性行为，他们指的是女同性恋，这完全是神话和完全的捏造。但他们用这个作为棍棒来打击她。所以我认为女性在法国大革命中确实受到了非常粗暴的对待，但她们所有人都是。所以即使是……所以玛丽·杜巴利，她是路易十五的
mistress i mean she gets guillotined uh marie antoinette obviously um and as you say madame roland yeah and all of them get accused of kind of obscene sexual practices they do and even i tell you a terrible thing so marion's best friend is one called the process de lambal oh yeah and the september massacres in 1792 so this is when france is is is losing the war they think um the prussians are going to arrive at any moment in paris so what should we do i know what we'll do we'll go through the prisons and kill everybody but but dominic that's an example isn't it, of basically people within the convention saying, let's unleash hell.
情妇，我的意思是，她被送上了断头台。玛丽·安托瓦内特，显然。正如你所说的罗兰夫人，是的。她们都被指控有淫秽的性行为。她们确实有。甚至，我告诉你一件可怕的事，所以玛丽最好的朋友是一个叫朗巴尔亲王夫人的人。哦，是的。1792年的九月屠杀。所以这是当法国在输掉战争时，他们认为……普鲁士人随时会到达巴黎。所以我们该怎么办？我知道我们该怎么办，我们将穿过监狱，杀死所有人。但多米尼克，那是一个例子，不是吗？基本上国民公会里的人说，释放地狱吧。
Let's unleash hell. Yeah, no, exactly. And they go through and they drag out the Frances de Lamballe and there are various different accounts. Some of them may be sensationalised. But there's no doubt she was hideously murdered. She's mutilated. Her head is cut off.
释放地狱吧。是的，不，完全正确。他们走过去，把朗巴尔亲王夫人拖出来，有各种不同的说法。其中一些可能被夸大了。但毫无疑问，她被极其残忍地谋杀了。她被肢解了。她的头被砍了下来。
They take her head to a barber's and have the barber do the hair they take the head around paris kind of cafes then they stick it on a spike and they hoist it outside marion's window let's look at what we've done to your friend who you are supposedly um been having a lesbian affair with and and you i don't think anyone can hear this story without thinking there is a charge here a really unpleasant charge that there wouldn't be with a man and of course one of the people who uh was kept in the bastille although he's moved a few days before it gets stormed is the marquis de sade and yeah there is a kind of um background to all of this which again feeds into the idea of the aristocrat as as kind of a demonic pervert it's you know there's also Dangerous Liaisons, Le Clos and everything. This image of
他们把她的头带到理发店，让理发师做头发。他们带着头在巴黎的咖啡馆里转。然后他们把它插在长矛上，把它举在玛丽的窗外。“让我们看看我们对你的朋友做了什么，你据称和她有女同性恋关系。”而且你……我不认为任何人听到这个故事而不认为这里有一个指控，一个非常令人不快的指控，这在男人身上是不会有的。当然，其中一个被关在巴士底狱的人，虽然他在被攻占前几天被转移了，是萨德侯爵。是的，有一种……所有这一切的背景，这再次助长了贵族作为某种恶魔般的变态者的想法。你知道，还有《危险关系》、拉克洛等等。这种形象……
scheming aristocrats who view torture and sexual sadism as a source of pleasure is a really powerful part of the kind of swirl of attitudes and assumptions that is making up
阴谋诡计的贵族，他们将酷刑和性虐待视为快乐的源泉，是当时构成宣传和舆论气候的各种态度和假设中非常强大的一部分。
the propaganda and the climate is making up the propaganda and the climate of opinion at the time. Isn't there a case, Tom, that the people who are directing the revolution in its bloodiest phase, in the phase known as the Terror, 1793-4, these are young men, very young men. I mean, there are virtually none who are older than their mid 30s so they're very young men they're staying up late they're tanked up on wine they you know there aren't any women around and there's a there's a lot of kind of surging unfocused energy there
难道没有一种情况吗，汤姆，那些在革命最血腥阶段——即1793-4年的恐怖时期——指导革命的人，是年轻人，非常年轻的男人。我的意思是，几乎没有比30多岁更年长的。所以他们是非常年轻的男人，他们熬夜，喝得酩酊大醉，他们……你知道，周围没有女人，有一种……大量的、无焦点的能量，
which is expressing itself in exceedingly violent you know these are blokes who would be better off settling down with a nice woman. That's my take on the French Revolution. Okay, well, talking of unfocused energy, I wonder whether we shouldn't perhaps just take a break here, draw our breath, and when we come back,
这表现为极其暴力。你知道，这些家伙如果能和一个好女人安定下来会更好。这就是我对法国大革命的看法。好吧，说到无焦点的能量，我想我们是否应该在这里休息一下，喘口气，当我们回来时，
perhaps focus on the terror and Saint-Just and Robespierre, which obviously for English students of the French Revolution is always the kind of the most dramatic and I will love that. Let's do that. I'm Marina Hyde.
也许专注于恐怖时期、圣茹斯特和罗伯斯庇尔，这显然对于法国大革命的英国学生来说，总是最戏剧性的。我会喜欢那个。让我们这样做。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A,
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐余温》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking about the French Revolution and we're arriving at the terror, which of course for fans of Dickens, fans of Carlyle, fans of the Carry On films, is what it's all about. Carlyle and the Carry On films, you don't often hear them in the same breath. We've talked about the execution of the famous women
你好，欢迎回到《历史余温》。我们正在谈论法国大革命，我们正在进入恐怖时期，这当然对于狄更斯的粉丝、卡莱尔的粉丝、电影《随身携带》（Carry On）系列的粉丝来说，就是它的全部意义所在。卡莱尔和《随身携带》系列电影，你不会经常听到它们被相提并论。我们谈到了法国大革命中著名女性的处决，
in the French Revolution revolution of whom marion trinette of course is the most famous we should probably look at um louis the 16th because in a sense his execution kind of removes the prop that has held up the entire system of french government for centuries and centuries and centuries and in a sense it's the removal of the monarchy that then leaves everything open, isn't it? Yeah, it is. And I think once you get the removal of the monarchy, then the focus turns to... I mean, one thing we haven't really talked about
其中玛丽·安托瓦内特当然是最著名的。我们可能应该看看路易十六，因为在某种意义上，他的处决消除了几个世纪以来支撑整个法国政府体系的支柱。在某种意义上，正是君主制的废除才让一切都变得开放，不是吗？是的，确实。而且我认为一旦你废除了君主制，焦点就转向了……我的意思是，有一件事我们还没有真正谈到，
is the nation, the idea of the nation, which I think is really created by the French Revolution. So the nation is in the kind of the Declaration of the Rights of Man. Well, it's there in the oath of the tennis court, isn't it? I mean, the very idea of setting up a national assembly for the nation exactly then the nation becomes sovereign not the king i don't want to give you a kind of too much of a gift but obviously this idea of the
那就是国家，国家的概念，我认为这确实是由法国大革命创造的。所以国家在《人权和公民权宣言》中。好吧，它在网球场宣誓中，不是吗？我的意思是，建立一个国家议会的想法，正是为了国家。然后国家成为主权者，而不是国王。我不想给你太多的礼物，但显然这个国家神圣的想法，
nation being sacred um and once you've not going to take that and once you've taken the king out of the equation then the nation which is this big sort of amorphous ideal um becomes the focus and i think you're right that, you know, that also happens when the war is going on. So France is under siege. And at that point, there is this, you get this intense radicalisation, I think, as the search for enemies within to explain why things are going,
一旦你把国王从等式中剔除，那么国家——这个巨大的、无定形的理想——就成了焦点。而且我认为你是对的，你知道，这也发生在战争进行的时候。所以法国处于被围困状态。在这一点上，有这种……你得到了这种强烈的激进化，我认为，随着寻找内部敌人来解释为什么事情会……
scapegoats. So Robespierre, for example, he says, you know, he was against the death penalty. Would you believe Robesp rob spear before the terror is one of his most famous things was he was he was against capital punishment he thought so was so was dr guillotine yeah dr well he just he didn't invent the guillotine he just wants them to do it because he thinks it's cleaner and he didn't want executions at all but he thought that if we've got to have them we might as well have a yeah so and he's the guy who who takes him into who leads them into the tennis court.
替罪羊。比如罗伯斯庇尔，他说，你知道，他曾反对死刑。你能相信吗？罗伯斯庇尔在恐怖统治之前，他最著名的事情之一就是反对死刑，他认为——吉约坦医生也是这么想的。是的，医生，他并没有发明断头台，他只是想让他们使用它，因为他认为这样更干净，而且他根本不想要处决，但他认为如果非要处决不可，那我们不妨用这种方式。是的，所以他就是那个带领他们进入网球场的人。
Is he? I did not know. That is a good fact. So everything fits together. It's a great conspiracy, right? It's the Freemasons, isn't it? So anyway, Rob Spear, he basically says, Louis must die so that the nation can live.
是他吗？我不知道。这是一个很好的事实。所以一切都吻合了。这是一个伟大的阴谋，对吧？是共济会，对吧？总之，罗伯斯庇尔基本上说，路易必须死，这样国家才能生存。
So, you know, there's almost this sort of great sacrificial moment. But once you've sacrificed one person and it's not working out, then you maybe need to sacrifice some more. And I think this is what happens. They just start feeding people into the more of the guillotine, if the guillotine can be a more. And things don't go well. And so Rob Spear, for example, he thinks, you know,
所以，你知道，这几乎是一种伟大的牺牲时刻。但一旦你牺牲了一个人，而事情并没有好转，那么你可能需要牺牲更多的人。我认为这就是发生的事情。他们只是开始把人送进断头台的“大嘴”里，如果断头台可以被称为大嘴的话。事情进展得并不顺利。所以罗伯斯庇尔，例如，他认为，你知道，
we want a pure, virtuous, republican France. And so we just need to keep getting rid of people until we find it. Well, there's that famous cartoon, isn't there, of Rose Pierre with guillotines in the background, and he is executing the executioner. And he's executed everybody else in France, guillotining the last person in France. Yes, that's right. Guilting the last person in France. I mean, this is exactly... So, I think this is the thing about the French Revolution that actually makes it linger in the imagination. It's not that they are just executing aristocrats and their enemies
我们想要一个纯洁、高尚、共和的法国。所以我们只需要不断地清除异己，直到找到它。嗯，有一幅著名的漫画，不是吗？罗伯斯庇尔站在断头台前，他正在处决刽子手。他已经处决了法国的所有人，正在处决法国的最后一个人。是的，没错。处决法国的最后一个人。我的意思是，这正是……所以，我认为这就是法国大革命让人在想象中挥之不去的原因。并不是因为他们只是在处决贵族和他们的敌人，
because that's kind of understandable. It's that they're executing each other. And they're not really executing aristocrats, are they? No. I mean, per se... Loads of the aristocrats have fled. They've gone. But there are aristocrats who hang around and you know that's well i mean actually here's a great question um from uh brecht um saval call who asks who is the closest modern equivalent of philippe egalite and why is it prince harry so philip egalitate the former duke of orleans the
因为那在某种程度上是可以理解的。而是因为他们在互相残杀。他们并不是真的在处决贵族，对吧？不。我的意思是，本身……大量的贵族已经逃跑了。他们走了。但也有一些贵族留了下来，你知道，其实这里有一个很好的问题，来自布雷希特·萨瓦尔·卡尔，他问谁是菲利普·平等（Philippe Égalité）最接近的现代对应人物，为什么是哈里王子？所以菲利普·平等，前奥尔良公爵，
cousin of of louis the 16th himself who actually votes i mean he's he's he's a he's a citizen in the and and the trial of louis and votes to have him yeah so he is a terrible man and he is prince harry he um he votes for his own cousin's execution. And he's kind of more Republican than the Republicans. I mean, that's his thing. He changes his name. Imagine changing your name. I mean, we live in a country. Lots of people do.
路易十六本人的堂兄，他实际上投票——我的意思是，他是一个公民，在路易的审判中投票支持处决他。是的，所以他是一个可怕的人，他是哈里王子，他投票支持他自己堂兄的处决。而且他比共和党人更像共和党人。我的意思是，这就是他的特点。他改了名字。想象一下改名字。我的意思是，我们生活在一个国家。很多人都这样做。
Yeah, well, we live in a country that now has, don't we now have in Birmingham, isn't there sort of equality, close, diversity way and all this kind of thing? It's only a matter of time before Prince Harry renames himself kindness or something, isn't it? But also in this, I mean, you know, I think we're being slightly harsh because you were casting it all as kind of blood and hypocrisy. Yeah. I mean, there are also hugely positive ideals here, perhaps exemplified by the way in which people are looking to the heroism of the Roman past. Well, if you want to go down that road,
是的，好吧，我们生活在一个现在有——我们在伯明翰不是有某种平等、包容、多元化之路之类的东西吗？哈里王子改名叫“善良”之类的只是时间问题，不是吗？但同时，我的意思是，你知道，我认为我们有点苛刻了，因为你把这一切都描述为血腥和虚伪。是的。我的意思是，这里也有非常积极的理想，也许可以通过人们寻求罗马过去的英雄主义的方式来体现。好吧，如果你想走那条路，
I mean, you clearly do. Heroic figures who are ready to sacrifice themselves for the nation, for the patria, for la patrie. Yeah. Do you find that noble? I think that both Saint-Just, who is clearly the coolest and most terrifying of all the French revolutions.
我的意思是，你显然想走。那些准备为国家、为祖国牺牲自己的英雄人物。是的。你觉得这很高尚吗？我认为圣茹斯特（Saint-Just），他显然是所有法国革命者中最酷、最可怕的一个。
But I mean, kind of rock star glamour to him. Well, he's in his very early 20s, isn't he, when it all kicks off? I mean, he's a very young man. But all the Jacobins are, when they say that they are motivated by virtue, they are motivated by virtue. But that's what makes them terrifying, though, Tom. That they're not corrupt. I was thinking about this with rob sphere when
但我的意思是，他有一种摇滚明星般的魅力。嗯，这一切开始的时候他才20出头，不是吗？我的意思是，他是一个非常年轻的人。但所有的雅各宾派都是这样，当他们说他们受到美德的激励时，他们确实是受到美德的激励。但那正是让他们变得可怕的地方，汤姆。他们并不腐败。我在想罗伯斯庇尔的时候，
this morning when i knew we were going to be in the podcast i was thinking what is it about him that makes him such a disturbing figure which i think he is and it is that he's not vladimir putin he's not he's not a corruptible a cold-blooded autocrat he's a cold-blooded high-minded do-gooder and that's what i think people find so resonant about him that he is the paradigmatic example of what happens when you have somebody who basically says i'm going to fix society i'm going to clean terror yeah dominic terror is nothing but prompt severe inflexible justice it is therefore an emanation of virtue is that robespierre that's robespierre yeah yeah he is i mean he is pushing to the limits a sense of how radically can you pull down what you see as being corrupt and evil and how readily can you put something in its place? There's a lesson here for the National Trust.
今天早上我知道我们要录播客时，我在想他身上有什么让他成为一个如此令人不安的人物，我认为他确实是，那就是他不是弗拉基米尔·普京，他不是一个可腐蚀的、冷血的独裁者，他是一个冷血的、高尚的行善者，这就是我认为人们觉得他如此引起共鸣的原因，他是当有人基本上说“我要修复社会，我要清洗”时所发生事情的典型例子。恐怖，是的，多米尼克，恐怖除了是迅速、严厉、不妥协的正义之外什么也不是，因此它是美德的体现。那是罗伯斯庇尔说的吗？那是罗伯斯庇尔，是的，是的，我的意思是，他正在把一种感觉推向极限，即你能多彻底地推翻你认为腐败和邪恶的东西，你能多容易地用别的东西取而代之？这对国民信托基金来说是一个教训。
Well, I mean, because we were talking about culture wars, I mean, in a sense, there is a kind of all that, you know, reminding people that great buildings, you know, there is no monument of civilization that is not also a monument of barbarism yeah uh that that concept i mean the moment you you get rid of the you abolish the monarchy not just because the monarch is inadequate but because the very institution of monarchy is a barbarous legacy of superstition and oppression then you have to you you you have to go flat out not just against the king,
嗯，我的意思是，因为我们在谈论文化战争，从某种意义上说，有一种……你知道，提醒人们伟大的建筑，你知道，没有一座文明的纪念碑不是同时也是一座野蛮的纪念碑。是的，那个概念，我的意思是，当你废除君主制时，不仅仅是因为君主不称职，而是因为君主制本身就是迷信和压迫的野蛮遗产，那么你就必须全力以赴，不仅要反对国王，
but against the entire institution. So revolutionaries head off to Saint-Denis, which was the kind of Westminster Abbey of French royalty. And they dig up all the bodies of the kings and queens and put them in a lime pit and dissolve them. And I think the only one that got away was Henry IV. Right. I wonder why. So they kept his head because I think he was a bit of a culture hero. And the only other one was some reason the heart of Louis XIV was preserved. And it got taken to England where it got eaten by William Buckland,
还要反对整个制度。所以革命者前往圣但尼，那是法国皇室的威斯敏斯特教堂。他们挖出了所有国王和王后的尸体，把它们放进石灰坑里溶解了。我想唯一逃过一劫的是亨利四世。对。我想知道为什么。所以他们保留了他的头，因为我想他算是一个文化英雄。唯一剩下的另一个是路易十四的心脏，出于某种原因被保存了下来。它被带到了英国，被威廉·巴克兰吃掉了，
who was the Dean of Westminster, who also named the first dinosaur. And he liked to eat everything he could. And he came across this and got told it's the heart of a French king. And he ate it. That's the best fact I think we've ever had on the rest of history. Yeah, well, you're welcome. You're welcome. But it's slightly diverted.
他是威斯敏斯特的院长，也是第一个恐龙的命名者。他喜欢吃他能吃到的一切。他偶然发现了这个，被告知这是法国国王的心脏。然后他就把它吃了。我认为这是我们在《历史的其余部分》中听过的最好的事实。是的，好吧，不客气。不客气。但这有点偏题了。
But anyway, so there's an aim to humiliate and downgrade the figure of Louis himself. So he gets shorn on the scaffolding. He gets treated just like anyone else. His body gets taken away, put in a rough coffin. Again, the kind of lime gets put on it so that none of his remains will be left. The same happens to the memorials of the kings. All the statues get pulled down. But you also have the same process happening with the church, which likewise is seen as a bastion of feudalism and superstition so kind of a a kind of
但总之，他们的目的是羞辱和贬低路易本人。所以他在脚手架上被剪了头发。他被像其他人一样对待。他的尸体被带走，放进一个粗糙的棺材里。同样，上面撒了石灰，这样他就不会留下任何遗骸。国王的纪念碑也发生了同样的事情。所有的雕像都被推倒了。但你也会看到同样的过程发生在教会身上，教会同样被视为封建主义和迷信的堡垒，所以这是一种……
revolutionary equivalent of the dissolution of the monasteries it's exactly that isn't it but it's also it's also tom this this obsession with rationalism and uniformity isn't it because it's not just that they do all that. They're renaming, changing the calendar, you know, moving to sort of, don't they try to move to a 10-day week? But also the metric system. The metric system. Which, of course, you could view as being
革命版的解散修道院，完全是这样，不是吗？但这也是，这也是，汤姆，这种对理性主义和统一性的痴迷，不是吗？因为他们不仅仅是做了所有这些。他们正在重命名，更改日历，你知道，转向某种……他们不是试图转向10天一周吗？还有公制系统。公制系统。当然，你可以认为这是
perhaps the most enduring act of legislation passed by. I think you can definitely argue that. I think the metric system, the new names for all the months, obviously, which don't catch on, the kind of uh termidor and uh prairie and brumaire and all that sort of thing so it's basically this remaking the world from year zero i mean obviously year one of the revolution year two of the revolution and and i'm you've shown great self-restraint and not mentioning
也许是他们通过的最持久的立法。我认为你绝对可以这样争辩。我认为公制系统，所有月份的新名称，显然没有流行起来，那种热月、牧月、雾月之类的东西，所以这基本上是从零年开始重塑世界，我的意思是显然是革命元年、革命二年，而且你表现出了极大的克制，没有提到
robs you know where we're going i do do. Rob's there in the Supreme Being. I do. Well, I've hugely resisted the temptation to quote Ernst Bloch's famous comment on the French Revolution that it is the Christian event par excellence because it is invoking all kinds of Christian ideas of new beginnings. So just we date our years from the incarnation. The French revolutionaries wanted to cast their revolution as an event of a kind of similar epical significance. And their attitude towards kind of, you know, an apocalyptic day of judgment, the last being first,
罗伯斯庇尔，你知道我们要去哪里。我知道。好吧，我极力抵制了引用恩斯特·布洛赫关于法国大革命的著名评论的诱惑，即它是基督教事件的典范，因为它援引了各种关于新开端的基督教思想。所以我们从道成肉身开始计算我们的年份。法国革命者想把他们的革命描绘成一种具有类似时代意义的事件。他们对某种世界末日的审判日、最后变为第一、
the first being last, it's all kind of, it's all written in there. But you're right. Essentially, what Robespierre wanted to do was to absolutely commit to the idea of reason as being the supreme being. And so Notre Dame is converted into a shrine for the supreme being. And it's a bit like Akhenaten, I guess. I mean, that's the thing that most reminds me of. That's a good comparison. So Akhenaten pulling down the statues of the traditional gods
第一变为最后的态度，这一切都写在里面了。但你是对的。本质上，罗伯斯庇尔想要做的是绝对致力于将理性视为最高存在的想法。所以巴黎圣母院被改造成了最高存在的圣殿。这有点像阿肯那顿，我想。我的意思是，这是最让我联想到的一点。这是一个很好的比较。所以阿肯那顿推倒了传统神的雕像，
and enshrining this rather kind of bloodless deity in their place that people emotionally couldn't connect with. And Dominic, this is one for you as a Tolkien fan. Do you know what the image, the favoured image that Rosepear had for the supreme being is it a tree?
并取而代之供奉了这个相当冷血的神，人们在情感上无法与之建立联系。多米尼克，这是一个给你的问题，作为一个托尔金粉丝。你知道罗伯斯庇尔最喜欢的最高存在的形象是什么吗？是一棵树吗？
no it's a disembodied eye oh wow but that's quite a sort of Freemasonish thing isn't it that's sort of lurking around in the 18th century I mean that festival of the supreme being I can remember, we did the French Revolution
不，是一个无形的眼睛。哦，哇，但这在18世纪潜伏着，这是一种相当共济会的东西，不是吗？我的意思是，那个最高存在节，我记得，我们学过法国大革命，
at school when I was about 12, and that was the thing that stuck in my mind that it happens in the middle of the terror. So they basically take a break. Robespierre is signing hundreds of death sentences.
我在学校大约12岁的时候，那是留在脑海里的事情，它发生在恐怖统治期间。所以他们基本上休息了一下。罗伯斯庇尔正在签署数百份死刑判决书。
I think he signed something like 600, between 500 and 600. And he basically takes a day off in the middle of this to go and inaugurate this festival of this sort of
我想他签署了大约600份，在500到600之间。他基本上在中间休了一天假，去参加这个某种
slightly made-up god god in which he's wearing this special new sky blue coat that he's very proud of and he's got a sash and actually a lot of his colleagues are laughing at him and they're they're sort of muttering behind their hands at him you know this you know he's loving this he's gone a bit mad and it's one of those moments where actually although it's his apotheosis the the mood is kind of slipping away from him a bit there because he looks ridiculous to some of the others they don't go along i'm not sure that i mean i i think that um kind of lurking behind it is is and forgive me for saying this but it's the kind of the the book of revelation the idea that an end time has come where sheep and the goats are being divided, great spectacles of blood, but also of building a new Jerusalem.
稍微有点虚构的神的节日，他穿着他非常自豪的这件特别的新天蓝色外套，他系着腰带，实际上他的许多同事都在嘲笑他，他们在背后对他嘀咕，你知道，他疯了，这是其中一个时刻，实际上虽然这是他的神化，但气氛有点从他手中溜走了，因为在其他人看来他很可笑，他们不买账。我不确定，我的意思是，我认为……某种潜伏在它背后的是——请原谅我这么说——它是《启示录》那种东西，末日已经到来，绵羊和山羊正在被分开，伟大的血腥奇观，但也包括建立一个新的耶路撒冷。
And that's essentially what, in secular terms, in rational terms, Robespierre is trying to do. But he's also doing it, though, Tom, at a time when you can't forget they're doing it at a time when the Prussians are almost at the gates. They're coming closer all the time. So it's not just that he thinks he's building New Jerusalem, but he thinks that the people who surround him. So he thinks a lot of his colleagues are actually secret British agents who are working for William Pitt. So there's this sort of weird paranoia.
这本质上就是罗伯斯庇尔在世俗层面、理性层面试图做的事情。但他这样做的时候，汤姆，你不能忘记他们是在普鲁士人几乎兵临城下的时候做的。他们越来越近了。所以他不仅认为自己在建立新耶路撒冷，而且他认为他周围的人——所以他认为他的许多同事实际上是为威廉·皮特工作的秘密英国特工。所以有一种奇怪的偏执。
That's not just a kind of religious paranoia, but it's also they know that. A genuine paranoia. Yeah. Well, they know that thereia yeah yeah well they know that there are lots of thousands of men out to kill them you know a couple of hundred miles away yeah okay well here's a question from fergal o'shea who asked why did rose pierre unlike stalin lose control of his purge both purge left a bear kamenev zinoviev and right danton bukarin but rose pierre ended up purged himself. Oh, Stalin is a much more
这不仅仅是一种宗教偏执，而且他们也知道。一种真正的偏执。是的。好吧，他们知道有成千上万的人要杀他们，你知道，在几百英里外。是的，好吧，这里有一个来自费格尔·奥谢的问题，他问为什么罗伯斯庇尔不像斯大林那样控制住他的清洗？两次清洗，左派的埃贝尔、加米涅夫、季诺维也夫，右派的丹东、布哈林，但罗伯斯庇尔最终自己被清洗了。哦，斯大林是一个比罗伯斯庇尔
potent political figure than Robespierre is. I mean, Stalin plans everything very cold-bloodedly and is very pragmatic and knows exactly what he's doing. Robespierre I don't think quite knows what he's doing. Robespierre is suffused with this idea of virtue, but also Robespierre makes a series of hideous tactical mistakes.
更有权势的政治人物。我的意思是，斯大林非常冷血地计划一切，非常务实，非常清楚自己在做什么。我不认为罗伯斯庇尔完全知道自己在做什么。罗伯斯庇尔充满了这种美德的观念，但罗伯斯庇尔也犯了一系列可怕的战术错误。
So he does this thing just before they get rid of him, where he basically goes to the convention. He gives a speech saying he's going to clamp down on his new set of enemies, but he doesn't say who they are. So everybody thinks, well, is it me? Could be me, yeah. Yeah, I think we should get rid of him because it's probably going to be me. And that's just a mad...
所以他在他们除掉他之前做了这件事，他基本上去了国民公会。他发表了一次演讲，说他要打击他的一批新敌人，但他没有说他们是谁。所以每个人都在想，嗯，是我吗？可能是我是吧。是的，我想我们应该除掉他，因为那个人很可能是我。这简直是一个疯狂的……
I mean, I think at the end, Rob Spear was... He'd lost... He's working 23-hour days or something. They've completely lost... These are guys who five years earlier were just provincial lawyers who are suddenly faced with this collapsing economy, this country in revolution, large parts of the country rising up against them.
我的意思是，我认为最后，罗伯斯庇尔……他失去了……他每天工作23小时之类的。他们完全失去了……这些人五年前还只是地方律师，突然面临着这个崩溃的经济、这个处于革命中的国家、国家的大部分地区都在反抗他们。
He's trying to bring in a new religion. He's trying to rename the calendar. He's trying to control prices and fight a war. And it's all just too much. But as David Nielsen reminds us with his comment, could the role of alcohol be said to be critical in the revolution, not simply among the people, but in the Committee of Public Safety? I've heard their bar bill was shocking.
他试图引入一种新宗教。他试图重命名日历。他试图控制价格并进行战争。这一切都太多了。但正如大卫·尼尔森在评论中提醒我们的那样，酒精的作用是否可以说是革命中的关键，不仅在人民中间，而且在公共安全委员会中？我听说他们的酒吧账单很惊人。
So they're all off their faces. I mean, they're pissed off their heads. Yeah, I think they probably are. Although it's weird. So, Danton is the most sort of, the biggest sort of gourmand. He eats and drinks, you know, for France. Well, he's played by Gérard Depardieu in the great film. Brilliantly, by Gérard Depardieu.
所以他们都喝醉了。我的意思是，他们喝得烂醉。是的，我想他们可能确实是。虽然这很奇怪。所以，丹东是那种最……最大的美食家。他为法国吃喝。嗯，他在那部伟大的电影中由杰拉尔·德帕迪约饰演。非常出色，由杰拉尔·德帕迪约饰演。
And there's a scene where he and Robespierre go for a meal, a reconciliation meal, and Robespierre is horrified by Danton stuffing himself with pies and oysters or something. And Danton is saying, he's saying, mange, Maxime, mange, trying to encourage him to eat. And Robespierre won't do it. But in reality, the Montagnard,
有一个场景，他和罗伯斯庇尔去吃饭，一顿和解餐，罗伯斯庇尔对丹东塞满馅饼和牡蛎之类的东西感到震惊。丹东说，他说，“吃吧，马克西姆，吃吧”，试图鼓励他吃。罗伯斯庇尔不肯。但在现实中，山岳派，
so Robespierre and his crowd, held Danton's overeating against him. They thought it was counter-revolutionary and unpatriotic and a sign of his sort of, that he must be working for William Pitt. Yes, he was shoveling him British beef. Yeah. On the side. Yeah, and they called the mountain, aren't they?
也就是罗伯斯庇尔和他的那一群人，对丹东的暴饮暴食耿耿于怀。他们认为这是反革命的，是不爱国的，是他某种……他一定是在为威廉·皮特工作的标志。是的，他是在给他塞英国牛肉。是的。在旁边。是的，他们称之为山岳派，不是吗？
Because they're on the top. Top benches. The top seats, the top benches. Yeah, yeah. I always distrust people who sit at the top in a lecture theatre because I think they probably have dangerously... Revolutionary terrorist tendencies. Yeah, exactly.
因为他们在顶部。顶部的长椅。顶部的座位，顶部的长椅。是的，是的。我总是怀疑那些坐在演讲厅最高处的人，因为我想他们可能有着危险的……革命恐怖主义倾向。是的，完全正确。
Okay, so the story of how Robespierre falls, I mean, it's a horrible one, isn't it? Because it involves a hanging jaw. So his jaw, yeah, horrible histories has a lot of fun with this. So they turn against Robespierre. He gives this disastrous speech. He's heckled in the convention. A lot of the other deputies,
好吧，那么罗伯斯庇尔倒台的故事，我的意思是，这是一个可怕的故事，不是吗？因为它涉及到一个下垂的下巴。所以他的下巴，是的，可怕的历史对这个很有趣。所以他们反对罗伯斯庇尔。他发表了这次灾难性的演讲。他在国民公会中被起哄。许多其他代表，
and it's not just a right-wing reaction. There's a lot of people on the left. There are actually people who are bigger on the terror than he is, who think he's, you know, I've got to get him before he gets me. So there's this sort of turn against him. They go to arrest him. He decides he's never used a gun before in his life.
这不仅仅是右翼的反应。左派也有很多人。实际上有些人比他更热衷于恐怖统治，他们认为他，你知道，我必须在他除掉我之前除掉他。所以有一种反对他的转向。他们去逮捕他。他决定——他一生中从未用过枪。
I mean, he's basically, you know, he's such a kind of guardian reading type he's never handled a firearm he doesn't but he's he doesn't know what he's doing he tries to blow his head off he kind of it's unclear what happens but he basically blows half his jaw off and it's hanging it has to be bandaged on and so that when they take him be beheaded, the executioner pulls off the bandage and his jaw kind of falls off and he gives this terrible animal shriek before they behead him. And then they behead him and then that's the end of him.
我的意思是，他基本上，你知道，他是一个那种读《卫报》类型的人，他从未接触过枪支，他不知道自己在做什么，他试图自杀，他有点——不清楚发生了什么，但他基本上炸掉了半个下巴，它悬挂着，必须用绷带包扎，所以当他们带他去斩首时，刽子手扯掉了绷带，他的下巴掉了下来，他在被斩首前发出了可怕的动物般的尖叫。然后他们斩首了他，然后这就是他的结局。
But you know, the weird thing, Tom, is that for most of the 20th century, the main chair in French Revolution history, the Sorbonne, was occupied by people who were Robespierre fans. So French historiography in the 20th century, a lot of it was a kind of defense of Robespierre and the Jacquemin and the terror. And actually, it was only in the 1980s that people really started to fight against that and say, well, actually, maybe the terror was a bad business. Well, there's another question here from Chet Archbold, who has sent in a question before. What do you make of the view, which I guess is the Simon Sharma view, that the violence
但你知道，奇怪的事情是，汤姆，在20世纪的大部分时间里，索邦大学法国大革命历史的主要教席都被罗伯斯庇尔的粉丝占据着。所以20世纪的法国史学，很大程度上是对罗伯斯庇尔、雅各宾派和恐怖统治的一种辩护。实际上，直到20世纪80年代，人们才真正开始反击，说，嗯，实际上，也许恐怖统治是一件坏事。好吧，这里还有来自切特·阿奇博尔德的另一个问题，他以前也发过问题。你如何看待那种观点，我想那是西蒙·沙玛的观点，即暴力
was inherent to the revolution right from the beginning? So that's a key question, isn't it, really? Yeah. Was it always going to end up with guillotines? This is your Margaret Thatcher versus François Mitterrand question, isn't it? So I thought we talked about this in a previous episode about how when they have the big Span-Bicentenary,
从一开始就是革命固有的？所以这是一个关键问题，不是吗，真的？是的。它总是会以断头台告终吗？这是你关于玛格丽特·撒切尔对阵弗朗索瓦·密特朗的问题，不是吗？所以我以为我们在上一集中谈论过这个，关于当他们举行盛大的两百周年纪念时，
everybody else turns up and talks about human rights. And she turns up and she gives Mitterrand, did she give him a leather-bound copy of A Tale of Two Cities? Yes, she did. She did. But you know, equally what Mitterrand said about the revolution in in
其他人都会出现并谈论人权。而她出现了，她给了密特朗——她给了他一本皮装的《双城记》吗？是的，她给了。她给了。但你知道，同样，密特朗关于革命所说的，在
1989 was that he admired it because it was still feared wow that's like you talking about tony blair yes um um no no no i mean so but but you know and and still in french politics now there because in 1793 it's legislated that the the French people have not just the right, but kind of the responsibility to launch insurrections if the revolution is being portrayed. And you will still, you know, in the Gilets Jaunes, people were citing that as a justification for what they're doing. It's remembered completely differently in France, weirdly, despite the fact that it was so traumatic and that so many tens and hundreds of thousands of people died, it's remembered, you know, there are more French Revolution partisans in France than in Britain. So in Britain, the tendency has been to emphasize the violence.
1989年，他说他钦佩它，因为它仍然令人恐惧。哇，这就像你谈论托尼·布莱尔一样。嗯，不，不，我的意思是，所以但是你知道，而且在现在的法国政治中，因为在1793年，法律规定法国人民不仅有权，而且有某种责任在革命被背叛时发动起义。你仍然会，你知道，在“黄马甲”运动中，人们引用这一点作为他们所作所为的理由。在法国，它的记忆方式完全不同，奇怪的是，尽管它如此痛苦，而且成千上万的人死亡，但它被记住了，你知道，法国的法国大革命支持者比英国多。所以在英国，倾向于强调暴力。
And Simon Sharma in his book Citizens, one reason a lot of people in France hated it was because Sharma said violence was the motor of the revolution. The revolution was violent from day one. And I think he's completely right. And I think Chet Archibald is right. So the Stormy of the Bastille, you know, a lot of people die in the Stormy of the Bastille. And the governor of the Bastille,
而西蒙·沙玛在他的书《公民》中，法国很多人讨厌它，原因之一是因为沙玛说暴力是革命的引擎。革命从第一天起就是暴力的。我认为他是完全正确的。我认为切特·阿奇博尔德是对的。所以攻占巴士底狱，你知道，很多人在攻占巴士底狱时死亡。而巴士底狱的总督，
who's basically this completely inoffensive, mid-ranking officer. You're defending the governor of the Bastille. What, Governor Delaney? You're such a counter-revolutionary, Dominic. Honestly, when the guillotine gets set up in Trafalgar Square. There are only seven people in the Bastille, so they drag him out,
他基本上是一个完全无害的中级军官。你在为巴士底狱的总督辩护。什么，德劳内总督？你真是个反革命，多米尼克。老实说，当断头台在特拉法加广场架起来的时候。巴士底狱里只有七个人，所以他们把他拖出来，
and everybody's stabbing him and punching him and stuff. He's basically being lynched by this crowd, and he lashes out and he kicks a pastry cook in the groin. Then the pastry cook stabs him to death, and a butcher comes along and uses a knife to sort of saw his head off, and the crowd are all cheering and whooping and stuff. I mean,
每个人都在刺他、打他之类的。他基本上被这群人私刑处死了，他反抗并踢了一个糕点师的腹股沟。然后糕点师把他刺死了，一个屠夫走过来用刀锯下了他的头，人群都在欢呼和尖叫之类的。我的意思是，
robust political discourse, Dominic. By any standards, you wouldn't see this in the streets of Northampton, Tom, and you know it. Well, chipping Norton,
强有力的政治话语，多米尼克。按照任何标准，你都不会在北安普顿的街头看到这个，汤姆，你知道的。好吧，奇平诺顿，
perhaps. Okay. Well, here's another counter-revolutionary question from Thoughtfully Detached, who I think is definitely a counter-revolutionary. The inheritors of the revolution have done their best to wipe the events in the Vendée out of the record books. Do both the brutality of the assault against the Vendéeans and their subsequent erasure
也许吧。好吧，这里有另一个来自“深思熟虑的超脱”的反革命问题，我认为他绝对是一个反革命。革命的继承者们已经尽其所能将旺代发生的事件从记录中抹去。对旺代人的残酷攻击及其随后的抹除
from history reveal essential truths about the French revolutionary project? So the Vendée is this kind of murderous civil war that's going along on in the Atlantic seaboard. Yes, in the West Front, the rural Catholic royalist. Yes, yes. And the repression is very, very, I mean, it's very brutal. It's basically near genocidal. I mean, there's no doubt about that.
是否揭示了关于法国革命计划的基本真理？所以旺代是这种在大西洋沿岸进行的某种血腥内战。是的，在西线，农村的天主教保皇党。是的，是的。而且镇压非常、非常——我的意思是，非常残酷。它基本上接近种族灭绝。我的意思是，毫无疑问。
I mean, just try and think of an analogy, Tom. Take your beloved Wiltshire. I mean, imagine, you know, there would have been some revolution like that in Britain and that then London has sent out troops to go and pacify Wiltshire and Dorset and they said oh basically
我的意思是，试着想一个类比，汤姆。以你心爱的威尔特郡为例。我的意思是，想象一下，你知道，英国发生过某种那样的革命，然后伦敦派出了军队去平定威尔特郡和多塞特郡，他们说，哦，基本上
they're not really signed up to the project so I think we should just kill them all I mean that's effectively what happens in the Vendee so the people still argue about the death toll
他们并没有真正加入这个计划，所以我认为我们应该把他们全部杀掉。我的意思是，这实际上就是旺代发生的事情。所以人们仍然在争论死亡人数，
but you're talking about hundreds of thousands of people and somewhere like Nantes people are being I mean they have mass drownings
但你谈论的是成千上万的人，像南特这样的地方，人们被——我的意思是，他们有大规模溺水，
not even mass shootings in the Loire don't they in the Loire yeah put them in cages and drop them in I mean really they have mass drownings. Yeah. Not even mass shootings. In the Loire, don't they? In the Loire, yeah. Put them in cages and drop them in. I mean, really horrific stuff. And actually, you know, for all the talk of the sort of the rights of man stuff, I mean, if your rights of man stuff is predicated on the fact you're going to have to drown a lot of people in cages, I mean. Okay, but so the fall of Rose Pierre and the crushing of the Vendée, I mean, that's not the end of the revolutionary process.
甚至不是在卢瓦尔河的大规模枪杀，不是吗？在卢瓦尔河，是的，把他们关进笼子里扔进去。我的意思是，真的有大规模溺水。是的。甚至不是大规模枪杀。在卢瓦尔河，不是吗？在卢瓦尔河，是的。把他们关进笼子里扔进去。我的意思是，真的很可怕。而且实际上，你知道，尽管谈论了所有关于人权的东西，我的意思是，如果你的“人权”东西是基于你必须把很多人关在笼子里淹死的事实，我的意思是。好吧，那么罗伯斯庇尔的倒台和旺代的镇压，我的意思是，那并不是革命进程的终点。
No, it keeps going. I mean, in 1795, so that's the year after the fall of Rose Pierre, there is talk of restoring the monarchy. Yeah, they're always royalist plots. Yeah, but it's not just that. I mean, because they've got Louis XVII. So this poor boy who's the son of Louis and Marie Antoinette, who's been brought up by an illiterate cobbler. And they're thinking, well, we could make him king because then he'd be a kind of, you know,
不，它还在继续。我的意思是，在1795年，也就是罗伯斯庇尔倒台后的那一年，有关于恢复君主制的讨论。是的，总是有保皇党阴谋。是的，但不仅如此。我的意思是，因为他们有路易十七。所以这个可怜的男孩，路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特的儿子，被一个文盲鞋匠抚养长大。他们想，嗯，我们可以让他当国王，因为那样他会成为一种，你知道，
that's basically what they want, isn't it? They want a cipher. They want to kind of puppet on the throne. You know, that would be an ideal constitutional monarch. And then you build everything around it. But then he dies and they're stuck with the guy who become louis the 18th who's this huge reactionary yeah yeah stuffing his face in gilford isn't it or something yeah he's i mean he's a man who basically says let's turn back the clock to 1500 or something i mean not an not not an
那基本上就是他们想要的，不是吗？他们想要一个密码。他们想要王位上的某种傀儡。你知道，那将是一个理想的立宪君主。然后你围绕它建立一切。但后来他死了，他们被困在了那个成为路易十八的人身上，他是一个巨大的反动派。是的，是的，在吉尔福德大吃大喝之类的，不是吗？是的，他——我的意思是，他是一个基本上说“让我们把时钟拨回1500年”之类的人，我的意思是，不是一个
inspiring model of what reaction might be he's a a sort of Daily Telegraph columnist figure, I think. So you've got the reactionaries, you've got the counter-revolutionaries, you've got the royalists. They're a part of the mix. You've also got, in 1797, a guy who's been described as perhaps the first communist, who's a man known as Babouf. Oh, yeah, Babouf, yeah. But you know, he was originally called François Noël yeah but you know his his he was originally called froswan
鼓舞人心的反动模式，他是一个《每日电讯报》专栏作家的形象，我想。所以你有反动派，你有反革命，你有保皇党。他们是混合体的一部分。你还有，在1797年，一个被描述为也许是第一个共产主义者的人，一个被称为巴贝夫的人。哦，是的，巴贝夫，是的。但你知道，他最初叫弗朗索瓦·诺埃尔。是的，但你知道他的——他最初叫弗朗索瓦·诺埃尔，
noel but you know what he changed his name to oh so good i've been so tempted to do this myself he changed his name to camillus gaius gracchus wow well that's the gracchi the gracchi were were kind of famous roman aristocrats who um were murdered by the roman elite for basically trying to stick up for the people so that you have this this journalist who's identifying himself with um with with dead roman aristocrats but who essentially is calling for a communist revolution yeah he's he's he's saying everything must be held in common and i think i mean no one's going to back he's never going to get any no of course not but but i mean it's it's a it's a sign of just how many points of view how many ideologies how many um people are involved in the kind of swirl of ideas and how much how how kind of plastic it is
但你知道他改名叫什么了吗？哦，太好了，我一直很想自己这样做。他改名叫卡米卢斯·盖乌斯·格拉古。哇，好吧，那是格拉古兄弟，格拉古兄弟是某种著名的罗马贵族，他们因为试图为人民挺身而出而被罗马精英谋杀，所以你有了这个记者，他把自己等同于死去的罗马贵族，但本质上是在呼吁共产主义革命。是的，他——他在说一切都必须共有，我想——我的意思是，没有人会支持他，他永远不会得到任何——当然不会，但我的意思是，这是一个标志，表明有多少观点、多少意识形态、多少人参与了这种思想的漩涡，以及它是多么的塑料，
how moldable it still is and i guess right right the way up to i mean the guy we haven't talked about but who who's whose shadow increasingly stretches over this conversation as we move forwards, which is that of Napoleon. Yeah. So Napoleon is a revolutionary officer. He suppresses a royalist plot, a royalist uprising with the famous whiff of great shot. He sort of comes to the fore in the late 1790s
它是多么的可塑，我想一直到——我的意思是，我们还没谈到但其阴影在谈话中越来越笼罩着我们的人，那就是拿破仑。是的。所以拿破仑是一名革命军官。他镇压了一场保皇党阴谋，一场保皇党起义，用著名的“一抹葡萄弹”。他在18世纪90年代末脱颖而出，
as a sort of leading the Republican armies in Italyaly and so on um and it's clear i think that you know maybe the analogy is sort of 1990s russia or something that the modern yeah that he's he's a guy who's been thrown up but who but in the sort of the course of events is great becomes a great hero because of his military conquest but there is a craving for stability but you know there's another But there's another more obvious historical parallel. But it's going to be a Roman one. It is a Roman one because the whole history, you know, the story of Rome is that you have a king, you expel the king, you establish a republic. The republic implodes amid blood and anarchy.
作为某种领导意大利等地的共和军，而且我认为很清楚，你知道，也许类比是某种20世纪90年代的俄罗斯之类的，现代的——是的，他是一个被抛出来的人，但在事件的过程中，因为他的军事征服而成为了伟大的英雄，但人们渴望稳定。但你知道，还有另一个——但还有另一个更明显的历史平行。但它会是一个罗马的。它确实是一个罗马的，因为整个历史，你知道，罗马的故事是你有一个国王，你驱逐了国王，你建立了一个共和国。共和国在血腥和无政府状态中内爆。
And then an imperial, you know, a warlord a caesarist comes in and establishes his rule and then he ends up losing to barbarians who've crossed the rhine and that essentially is the story from 1789 to 1815 yeah germanic barbarians very nice yeah wow the whole span of roman history is compressed into it but of course that's how they thought of it themselves tom of course it is i mean they are they're basically sort of roman republic reenactors who absolutely and that's that's the kind of amazing thing so you wonder you know to what extent is this obeying some kind of natural rhythm of history and to what extent is it all one enormous bloody cosplay it's it's a kind of really interesting question well of course marx thought there was a law of history didn't he thought bonapartism was bound to emerge from this sort of bourgeois
然后一个帝国，你知道，一个军阀，一个凯撒主义者进来了，建立了他的统治，然后他最终输给了跨越莱茵河的野蛮人，这本质上就是从1789年到1815年的故事。是的，日耳曼野蛮人，非常好，是的，哇，整个罗马历史的跨度被压缩在其中，但当然，他们自己就是这样想的，汤姆，当然是这样。我的意思是，他们基本上是某种罗马共和国的重演者，绝对是，这就是那种令人惊奇的事情，所以你怀疑，你知道，这在多大程度上是在服从某种历史的自然节奏，在多大程度上这一切都是一场巨大的血腥角色扮演？这是一个非常有趣的问题。好吧，当然马克思认为历史是有规律的，不是吗？他认为波拿巴主义注定会从这种资产阶级
revolution um but i think uh the one thing about napoleon is not i think it's a mistake to think napoleon turning the clock back from the revolution because of course a lot of those sort of things about rationalism about uniformity about a kind of liberalism. Napoleon incarnates those things. And he is exporting revolutionary ideals across Europe. Just he's doing it in quite an authoritarian and corrupt way. Yes. And also, of course, there is one obvious major moral blot on this scoochingon as a a kind of liberal reformer which is cited by ollie nichols um who mentions events in haiti yes yeah so yeah that's and actually a part of the french revolution i think will become even you know become bigger and bigger in the next few decades
革命中产生，但我认为，关于拿破仑的一点是，我不认为拿破仑把时钟从革命中拨回是一个错误，因为当然，很多关于理性主义、统一性、某种自由主义的东西。拿破仑体现了这些东西。他正在向欧洲出口革命理想。只是他以一种相当专制和腐败的方式这样做。是的。而且，当然，作为一个自由改革者，这上面有一个明显的重大道德污点，这是奥利·尼科尔斯提到的，他提到了海地发生的事件。是的，是的，所以——是的，实际上这是法国大革命的一部分，我认为在未来几十年里会变得越来越大，
because we're much more conscious of this side of the story so you're right the haitian revolution breaks out in the 1790s in response to what's been happening in France. And Napoleon, have you read that book Black Spartacus about Toussaint Louverture, one of the leaders of the Haitian Revolution? And I remember this quote from that stuck in my mind. Napoleon says the sort of blacks are rising up against the whites. I'm against the blacks because I'm white. I mean mean it's completely sort of unashamed about it yeah and one of the things
因为我们对故事的这一面更加清醒了。所以你是对的，海地革命在18世纪90年代爆发，以回应法国发生的事情。拿破仑，你读过那本关于海地革命领导人之一杜桑·卢维杜尔的《黑斯巴达克斯》吗？我记得其中这句让我印象深刻的话。拿破仑说，某种黑人正在反抗白人。我反对黑人，因为我是白人。我的意思是，这完全是对此毫不掩饰，是的，而且其中一件事
that the revolution the french revolution generally disrupts actually is france's is france's kind of imperial project so france loses you know the the french ports sort of bordeaux and so on they had traded in slaves they had traded in sugar and coffee and rum and things like that. And actually Napoleon goes to visit them after he becomes emperor. And he's horrified at how quiet the keys are because they're not trading in them anymore because of the Caribbean uprising and so on. And he wants to turn the clock back. He wants to rebuild France.
革命——法国大革命通常会破坏的，实际上是法国的某种帝国计划。所以法国失去了，你知道，法国的港口，波尔多之类的，他们曾从事奴隶贸易，他们曾从事糖、咖啡和朗姆酒之类的贸易。实际上，拿破仑在成为皇帝后去拜访了他们。他对码头如此安静感到震惊，因为他们不再进行这些贸易了，因为加勒比海起义之类的。他想把时钟拨回去。他想重建法国。
And that's why he wants to get rid of the Haitian revolutionaries. Although when he then escapes from Elba and comes back while all the various plenipotentiaries are in Vienna trying to draw up their new plan and Lord Castlereagh is pushing for abolitionism there, Napoleon suddenly comes out as an abolitionist as well. So I think on the issue of slavery, he is very shameless. I always think, I don't know what you think about this, Tom. I don't think we should have a separate one on Napoleon, but I think people who like Napoleon are like people who like Frank Sinatra's My Way. Okay, well. Don't you? No, I don't think.
这就是为什么他想除掉海地革命者。虽然当他后来从厄尔巴岛逃回来时，当所有各种全权代表都在维也纳试图制定他们的新计划，而卡斯尔雷勋爵在那里推动废奴主义时，拿破仑突然也成为了废奴主义者。所以我认为在奴隶制问题上，他是非常无耻的。我总是想，我不知道你怎么看这个，汤姆。我不认为我们应该单独做一期关于拿破仑的，但我认为喜欢拿破仑的人就像喜欢弗兰克·辛纳屈的《我的路》的人。好吧，好吧。你不觉得吗？不，我不认为。
I think they're people who look in the mirror and say to themselves, one day I shall be world king. You know who I'm thinking of. Listen, yes, I do. I think, however, that to look at the French Revolution in the global context. Yeah. So we've got a question from Diego Morgado, who's an enthusiast for the French Revolution. One of the most important events in world history.
我认为他们是那些照镜子并对自己说“总有一天我会成为世界之王”的人。你知道我在想谁。听着，是的，我知道。然而，我认为，从全球背景来看法国大革命。是的。所以我们有一个来自迭戈·莫尔加多的问题，他是法国大革命的爱好者。世界历史上最重要的事件之一。
I mean, yes, I think. Definitely. Don't you? Yeah, I suppose so. I suppose so. Yeah. yeah from left to right divide declaration of human rights rejection of monarchy and ability and religion there was a before and after even influenced places like Persia and China am I right I think he is right I think he is absolutely right and I think that the impact of the French revolution isn't just about the terror
我的意思是，是的，我想。绝对是。你不觉得吗？是的，我想是吧。我想是吧。是的。是的，从左右分歧、人权宣言、对君主制、贵族和宗教的拒绝，有一个“之前”和“之后”，甚至影响了波斯和中国等地，我说的对吗？我认为他是对的，我认为他是绝对正确的，而且我认为法国大革命的影响不仅仅在于恐怖统治
and kind of bloody warnings it is also about um enshrining ideas of human rights. It is about republicanism. It's about the idea that hidebound ideas can be banished with the light of progress and reason. And that these ideas, although the French Revolution kind of serves as a warning, and I think that the French Revolution definitely cranks up the fires of reaction to it. It does also serve as an inspiration. And that in that sense, what you talked about left and right being on either side of the president of the assembly, the French Revolution serves to set the political contours of not just European politics, but global politics for the centuries that have followed it. And that
和某种血腥的警告，它也在于……确立人权思想。它在于共和主义。它在于那种陈腐的思想可以用进步和理性的光芒来驱逐的想法。而且这些思想，虽然法国大革命在某种程度上起到了警告的作用，而且我认为法国大革命绝对加剧了对它的反动之火。它确实也起到了一种激励作用。而且从这个意义上说，你谈到的左右两派分别坐在议会主席的两侧，法国大革命不仅为欧洲政治，也为随后的几个世纪的全球政治设定了政治轮廓。而且那
is what makes it so seismically important. Yeah, I think there's a lot of truth in that. I mean, obviously, one reason why people love it so much is it's just a great melodrama. I mean, it's a fantastic story. But I also think, I mean, I think you could argue though, Tom, I mean, to sort of make my expected contribution, I think you could argue the French Revolution retards progress, because it tarnishes the idea of progress. And it certainly does in Britain and in the sort of English-speaking world. There is this, I mean, British reactionaries use it
正是这一点使其具有如此震撼的重要性。是的，我认为这其中有很多真理。我的意思是，显然，人们如此热爱它的一个原因在于它是一部伟大的情节剧。我的意思是，这是一个精彩绝伦的故事。但我认为，汤姆，你也可以争辩说——为了做出我预期的贡献——你可以认为法国大革命阻碍了进步，因为它玷污了进步的理念。它在英国和英语世界确实如此。我的意思是，英国的保守派利用它
throughout the whole 19th century as this sort of terrible... I think in Europe as well. Well, I think it's got so much traction in Britain because of Burke. Burke's Reflections on the Revolution in France, which is this colossal... I mean, it's the foundational text of conservatism. But basically, if you start messing with the system as it exists,
在整个19世纪将其视为一种可怕的……我想在欧洲也是如此。嗯，我认为它在英国之所以有如此大的影响力，是因为伯克。伯克的《对法国大革命的反思》是一部宏大的……我的意思是，它是保守主义的奠基之作。但基本上，如果你开始干扰现有的体制，
you will end up in a complete nightmare of... And the thing that makes it so powerful is that Burke wrote that before the terror. So he was right. He was proved right. And people have taken that ever since as the ultimate justification of conservatism. But I think there's an interesting parallel with the Reformation, where the Reformation obviously gives birth to Protestantism.
你最终会陷入一场彻底的噩梦……而让它如此有力的原因在于，伯克在恐怖时期之前就写下了这些。所以他是对的。事实证明他是对的。从那时起，人们一直将其视为保守主义的终极辩护。但我认为它与宗教改革有一个有趣的相似之处，宗教改革显然催生了新教。
But there is also an argument for saying that it gives birth to Catholicism in the sense that we understand it today. And in the same way, conservatism, royalism, reaction, after 1789, is a very different beast to the Ancien Régime. It exists as a reaction to the revolution, just as much as the politics on the left is a kind of natural progression from it. So in that sense, I think the French Revolution absolutely deserves its reputation as the great event of modern history. Do you think more than the, because we had a few questions, I can't, oh yes, Joseph Ruiz, he says, is it more important than the American Revolution?
但也有人认为，它催生了我们今天所理解的天主教。同样，1789年之后的保守主义、保皇主义和反动派，与旧制度下的事物截然不同。它作为对革命的反应而存在，就像左翼政治是其自然演变一样。因此，从这个意义上说，我认为法国大革命绝对配得上它作为现代史重大事件的声誉。你认为它比美国革命更重要吗？因为我们收到了一些问题，我不能……哦，是的，约瑟夫·鲁伊斯问，它比美国革命更重要吗？
Yes, massively. I mean, it's much more important than the American Revolution, isn't it? Absolutely. I've got a quote here from David Bell. Astonishingly, not once in the early years of the French Revolution does a single political figure seem to have quoted the American Declaration of Independence. Yeah, but that's because I think the American Revolution wasn't seen beyond America as a revolution. It was seen as a breakaway, but it's not a revolution in the same way, is it? I don't think so. It's a debate among Anglophones about Anglophone traditions,
是的，非常重要。我的意思是，它比美国革命重要得多，不是吗？绝对是。我这里引用大卫·贝尔的一句话：令人惊讶的是，在法国大革命的早期，似乎没有一位政治人物引用过《美国独立宣言》。是的，但那是因为我认为美国革命在美洲之外并没有被视为一场革命。它被视为一场分裂，但它不像法国大革命那样是一场革命，对吧？我不这么认为。这是英语国家之间关于英语传统的辩论，
whereas the French one, French revolution really does go kind of global. Anyway, I think that we have talked, well, we haven't talked enough about the French revolution. We could, we could talk about it for hours.
而法国大革命确实走向了全球。总之，我认为我们已经谈论了……好吧，我们谈论法国大革命还不够多。我们可以谈上几个小时。
I know. I'm looking at all the questions we haven't handled. I feel ashamed. I feel ashamed of myself. Yeah. Many apologies. I mean, maybe we can come back to it.
我知道。我看着所有我们还没处理的问题，感到很惭愧。我为自己感到惭愧。是的。非常抱歉。我的意思是，也许我们可以回头再谈。
There's so much more to, to talk about. God knows. I mean, we can come back to it in 2037 or something. I'm so optimistic about the future of the podcast. That's great. Yeah, of course.
还有太多东西要谈了。天知道。我的意思是，我们可以在2037年左右再谈。我对播客的未来充满乐观。那太好了。是的，当然。
Year zero. So many thanks for listening. Having talked about the French Revolution in this podcast, our next podcast will be on the subject of british food which is kind of hurrah the roast beef would approve but yeah so many thanks for listening and we will see you then i hope bye-bye au revoir Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
零年。非常感谢大家的收听。在这一期播客讨论了法国大革命之后，我们的下一期播客将讨论英国食物，这真是太棒了，烤牛肉一定会赞同的，但是的，非常感谢大家的收听，我们到时候见，希望如此，再见，再见。感谢收听《历史的余味》。如需收听额外剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在restishistorypod.com注册。网址是restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。